[Music]
i love this look of you and this moment
at the 2022 grammy awards it's the same
night you won for best gospel album what
was that moment like oh it was great i
felt like a princess
on the carpet the photographers were
like
give her a kiss
like we're not like a pda couple anyway
my husband certainly is not so i was
like is he going for it and then i was
like i'll just put my cheek out there
like i hope this doesn't
come off as awkward as it kind of feels
you made it look natural
okay how about this we're going back a
little bit so this is you in 2007 at the
grammys as a baby
it was the height of just everything
everything was crazy it's been crazy
ever since but it was just such a fun
night to be able to be there and be a
part of it and to win a couple grammys
it was a great night how about this
night
the winner
of american idol
2005
is
carrie underwood
i love your hair
[Applause]
that entire night was just over the top
it was just such an incredible night the
last five minutes were
super super crazy nervous but it was
wonderful and then my mom was like up on
stage with me and there's like confetti
everywhere
it was just it was really beautiful
[Applause]